all right so we have a a new mommy on
the Block huh yes I can't believe I love
it I mean the obvious question here is
how much has your life changed since
becoming a mom oh change so much for the
better I feel like you know what I saw
like the funness I still can cosplay and
do crazy things but like it's just fun
now because I have like a little like
partner and it's just so fun nothing
matters once you have a kid it's like
that's all that matters and like nothing
else matters so like I'm oblivious to
everything in the world and it's great
you're you're already so fun but I can
only imagine that now that you have your
little partner in crime everything's
elevated oh my gosh and she's like a
little girl so she's just like I get to
dress her up like I was excited boy or a
girl but now this is like a girl I was
like I'll have this like dresser like a
mini me and she's so much fun well I
mean you named her Malibu Barbie which
is Iconic and it just probably fits her
personality because it fits yours yes
yes she is
which is great but Maui Barbies like sun
Beach fun very specific yeah very
specific very Malibu Barbie so has there
been any part of motherhood that has
surprised you
oh my gosh all of it I don't think
anyone fully prepares you to be a mom um
or a parent and I just I
all of it I think it's like both easier
and harder than I thought on one hand
I'm like oh my gosh like you know
changing diapers all this stuff very
easy and then although it has like a lot
more difficult I'm like oh my gosh you
have to entertain this person and what
does she like to do she likes to look at
her handshakes with tags and you're just
like you're figuring it out all so it's
like easier and harder than I thought
but it's so perfect if somebody tells me
whatever she's into you're gonna be in
it's so cute
but her personal
so uniquely Her Like She's so different
and we're like where does she get this
just her little charm and everything
it's very oh I could tell where she gets
a problem Mom and Dad yeah yeah yeah
what would the Trish crying on the
kitchen right uh it makes like emotional
when I see that she'd be so happy I
never thought this would ever happen for
me marriage and a baby and all that so
she'd be so happy we got our life
together I don't by the grace of God for
real the universe soars anything you
want to call it like it it had it worked
out for us we just had to go through
that Journey now that your mom is it
easier to kind of like block out and
stay out of or away from YouTube drama
yeah
so nice
with that I kind of try and follow
things like on Tick Tock like top drama
and stuff and I don't get it but yeah I
think it's that like the drama part of
me is like a past thing it was but it
was fun I mean you know it's an iconic
moment to be drama for a minute right to
involve yourself in drama I think you
have to go through that I think that's
what people know me for so it's like
shifting now I mean I don't think I'd
have any input on drama anymore I'm just
so bold at this point like what do I
have to comment on any I don't even know
what the drama is but if there was
something I had no comment you have
stayed relevant and so active on social
media for over a decade what would you
say is the secret oh gosh uh you know
what just changing with the times I mean
I was drama so like getting your name
out there and being problematic I think
was but that was for the time I think
now it's like now it's cool to not be
problematic right it's not so I think
now it's just it's just changing with
the time y'all have seen us cry a lot on
the internet right individually now we
cry together you um now have a podcast
with Colleen which is awesome
um how did this come to be oh we've been
talking about it for so long so yeah
we've been friends for like 10 years I
became a mom and so we did like Mommy
mukbangs together and it just was like
we should do a podcast together she's so
busy I'm so busy but at the same time it
just kind of makes sense because we talk
about Mommy theater just being on the
internet for so long I mean have you
guys bonded over the fact that like at
this point you're an influencer mommy
yes yeah right totally yeah I think it's
we like started so young we were both
like 18 19 when we started on YouTube
and then now we're like we've gone
through highs and low she's had Netflix
and Broadway and I've gone through
messes and Celebrity Big Brother and
also and then now we're kind of at this
mommy stage and trying to figure out
what's next so it's we just like let's
do a podcast while we can I honestly it
makes sense yeah how different has like
your social time what five years ago
must have been so different than it is
oh totally yeah oh my God we would that
would be like in West Hollywood clubs at
night I went recently did it feel
different yeah I was just like it was
like nine o'clock I'm like oh my God no
one's here yet I'm like I can't have to
go home and then you're going they start
arriving yeah
how it changes you don't think you
change but you're like no I got old
who's coming on Mom I mean it's such an
amazing journey and now you like I said
have this partner in crime Malibu Barbie
were there any other names you were
considering you know malbert was my
first name and that was my first but we
were throwing our names out there my
husband liked like Kate and like those
kind of names and I was very like sugar
cookie and I like that so we had to find
the happy medium so I pitched Malibu
Malibu first and he's like Malibu's
Ocean and the Vibes and then I kind of
threw in Barbie last minute I was like
let's just put that as her middle name
nobody will know it really is kind of a
Vibe though yeah it's really good well I
feel like Malibu Barbie needs a Malibu
Ken now like have you thought about
expanding your family oh we're trying we
are trying yes we hope soon yeah we
would love to either have another little
Skipper or Ken like you said oh Skipper
yeah Barbie family okay so you're gonna
stick to the Barbie names
um maybe definitely pop culture we have
like a couple in our in our head but
definitely yeah
Moses thanks for letting us into your
home today I know you don't do this a
lot
um I mean you two are glowing and you're
making me feel so single
no I love your love I really do so Moses
when you first met Trisha on the H3
podcast did you know this is the one
I did when I first met her you did yeah
definitely that's so surprising to me I
didn't I didn't know that yeah because
we had we were a little water and oil at
the beginning of a really good I did not
put all the cards on the table at the
beginning but you had to earn her huh
yeah you had to work for him I tested
him a lot too let me ask you Moses what
is the secret to such a strong marriage
secret the true secret is no judgment
acceptance okay yeah we really took each
other as we are
that that makes sense because I heard
you were thinking of names like Kate for
your daughter yeah and now it's Malibu
do you love it though it's the best
night is it really is the best night
it's very much he introduces as her
first and last name I thought he was
just gonna go by Malibu but he does mama
Barbie too yeah what do you guys prefer
like I mean her first name is Malibu her
middle name's Barbie but she has
nicknames
what would you say Moses is the biggest
misconception of marriage in general
that something kind of stops evolving or
stop like we still get to know each
other we still get to fall in love even
deeper and more so I think marriage is
just the beginning of building something
big yeah you have to look at it as the
beginning not something that this is the
end and now it's going to be the same
yeah or that it's complete or this is
yeah yeah so something tells me life is
so much better with her
it was boring and it was so like I don't
know I was lonely and there was no fun I
never took a vacation before we met
really never like I didn't know what it
was oh literally that's so cool what do
you guys love to travel to
we've been everywhere how why we like
tropical Maldives like beachy kind of
videos where the food is good yeah life
in the public life comes with pros and
cons right good and bad you two have had
to endure horrible Reddit cheating
rumors so like how did you guys navigate
that together as a couple
well the reality is we're always
together yeah so it doesn't matter what
people say about me or her we know the
truth right because we're always
together yeah those workers are crazy
and the other side of it we're confident
in our relationship and our feelings in
our marriage so nothing can shake that
of course I could see it and I feel it
too yeah yeah my first relationships at
my other relationship I would I would be
scared because was this true is this let
me see your phone but now I'm like we
are together all the time I mean he
literally is the best husband he like he
dotes on me takes care of mouth like
he's just like he's been taking care of
us yeah you know why you've been getting
ready he you Moses greeted me for this
interview and said hi I'm the husband oh
yeah did you say that that's so funny
and offered me a drink it's like you you
this is your house like drinks that I
saw he like brought drinks out on a
trade everybody I just like he's really
good that way I need to be better he's
very good that way no you guys are
Partners thousands of Partnerships he
picks up everything that I lack and
[Music]